we're asked to divide ninety nine point
zero six one or ninety nine and sixty
one thousandth by one hundred and
there's a few ways to do it but I what I
want to do in this video is focus on
kind of a faster way to think about it
and hopefully it'll make sense to you
and that's also the focus of it that it
makes sense to you so 99 let's just
think about it a little bit so if we so
ninety-nine point zero six one so if we
were to divide this by ten just to make
the point clear if we were to divide
this by 10 what would we get well we
would essentially move the decimal place
one spot to the left and it should make
sense because we have a little over 99
if you took 99 divided by 10 you should
have a little over 9 so essentially you
would move the decimal place one to the
left when you divide by 10 so this would
be equal to nine point nine zero six one
if you were to divide it by a hundred so
if you were to divide which is actually
the focus of this problem so if we
divide 99 point zero six one divided by
100 if we move the decimal place once to
the left we're dividing by 10 to move it
divide it by 100 divided by 10 again so
we move it over twice so one two times
and so now the decimal place is out in
front of out in front of that first
leading 9 which also should make sense
99 is almost 100 we're a little bit less
than 100 so if you divide it by a
hundred we should be a little bit less
than one and so if you move the decimal
place two places over to the left
because we're really dividing by 10
twice if you want to think of it that
way we will get the decimal in front of
the 99 the point nine nine zero six one
we should put a zero out here just
sometimes it clarifies things so then we
get this right over here now I want to
think one way to think about although I
do want you to always imagine that when
you move the decimal place over to the
left you really are dividing by 10 when
you move it to the left when you move to
the right you're multiplying by 10
sometimes people say hey look you could
just count the number of zeros and if
you're dividing so over here you were
dividing by 100 100 has two zeros 100
has two zeros so and we're dividing by
it so
we can move our decimal two spaces to
the left that's all right to do that is
you know especially it's kind of a fast
way to do it if you're you know if this
had 2000 means let's say okay let's move
the decimal 20 places to the left but I
really want you to think about why
that's working why that makes sense why
it's giving you a number that seems to
be to be the right kind of size number
that this why why it makes sense that if
you take something that's almost 100 and
divide by 100 you'll get something
that's almost 1 and that part frankly is
just a really good reality check to make
sure you're going the right direction
with the decimal because Frank you know
if you tried this 5 10 years from now
maybe you're a little you your your
memory of the rule or whatever you want
to call it for doing it you're like hey
wait do I move the decimal to the left
or the right it's really good to do that
reality check to say okay look if I'm
dividing by 100 I should be getting a
smaller value and moving the decimal to
the left gives me that smaller value if
I was multiplying by 100 I should get a
larger value and moving the decimal to
the right would give you that larger
value